last week the Italian Supreme Court
ruled that public masturbation is not I
repeat not a criminal act this is a news
story yeah now it is not criminal acts
who publicly masturbate in Italy now I
just have to say I've been to Italy many
times I think it's a beautiful country I
love Italy and as someone who loves
Italy I think this is a huge mistake I
wanted to know what the Italian courts
were thinking so ladies and gentlemen a
great expense I have set up a satellite
interview with a senior clerk whom the
Italian Supreme Court although Ricci and
let's talk to him
hello there good evening gonna yes okay
now although tell us why did the Italian
Supreme Court decriminalize public
masturbation mmm
first of all let me assure the American
people that just because we
decriminalize public masturbation does
not mean the state approves of the
activity in any way shibi stop it stop
it stop it what are you doing the penal
consequences of the Act sir sir I'm
sorry I have to ask you are you
masturbating my cuff link is stuck in my
jacket I was trying to pull it out Conan
I'm very sorry I'm just I'm just telling
you from from our vantage point from
here it kind of just look like I know
what you think it looked like oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry please continue as I was
saying while public masturbation is no
longer a jailable offense it can still
be prosecuted as a civil violation for
example in your country if you drink
beer on the beach you get a ticket for
disorderly conduct but you don't go to
job oh wait a minute no wait a minute
sir did you just have an orgasm
Parvati yesterday I pulled my shoulder
playing tennis and just now as I was
unsticking my coupling my shoulder
popped back into place and I feel so
much better
I'm sorry it sounded and I have to say
it look like something else motive girl
yeah I have a family you're on a sight
better than Ito I'm sorry sir I'm sure
you are not a pedophile Tito okay but
tell us please when the court made its
ruling did the justices way the concerns
of women and families were out oh what a
pretty [ __ ] now just ignore that anyway
women and families who are out in public
are now more likely to run into perverts
committing with the vast majority the
population still regards as an obscene
[Applause]
wait a minute let me guess
you were opening a milk container when
you saw a cat you said what a pretty
[ __ ] the cat tried to get the milk you
pulled away the cat scratched you you
said ah you reflexively squeezed the
cardboard milk container yes
[Applause]
although Ricci of the Italian Supreme
Court thank you we'll be right back
Danny McBride is here
you